oh
à
depuis 1974 le domaine de ville elle est
devenue un lieu patrimonial
un musée qui livre l'histoire de ceux
qui ont bâti ses murs une riche famille
de planteurs créole les pannes ont des
bassins puis les villes elles un lieu où
se lisent aussi les grandes pages d'une
organisation sociale marquée par la
servitude qui prend pour nom esclavage
engagisme et colonat partiaire au delà
de ce qu'il met en scène et de ce qu'il
donne à voir
il est un espace entre les parenthèses
du temps où se côtoient imaginaire et
réalité madame desbassyns disparu le 4
février 1846 veille toujours le musée
historique de ville elles a une identité
propre et le film ville elle amusée
entre parenthèses on propose une lecture
poétique